you wouldn't
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I need help
[Applause]
[Applause]
no statement yesterday
[Music]
[Music]
just hazard preparedness
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hopefully we'll be posted tomorrow
morning journalists who are joining us
online you can click on raise hand on
your screen to get in queue for
questions those who are calling by phone
please dial star nine when you keep our
to be put in the in the queue tonight's
press conference will be short we have
no more than 45 minutes today as you
have seen in our mid advisory we will
talk about two topics today we had a
meeting of Emergency Committee and the
international regulations on Ebola
outbreak in the Republic of the Congo
and we will also talk about coverage 19
as we do on a daily basis today it does
beside the regular guests we also have
professor Robert Stefan who is its share
of HR emergency committee on on Ebola
disease outbreak in dr congo i'll just
go to the name is dr. marie paule kieny
who was a co-chair of the research
forward that just included dr. mike ryan
executive director for merchants east of
the terrace w director general we have
Sylvie Brown who is the director of
infectious hazard preparedness and our
chief scientist dr. Sonya swaminathan so
how do you flow immediately to go to
debtors
thank you tonic and good evening to all
colleagues who have joined from the
media and from our organization once
again I would like to thank what is it
Stefan and all the members of the
Emergency Committee on Ebola for their
time and advice the Emergency Committee
on Ebola has advised that the outbreak
in the Democratic Republic of Congo
continues to be a public health
emergency of international concern and I
have accepted that advice as I said
yesterday as long as there is a single
case of Ebola in an area as insecure and
unstable as eastern DRC the potential
remains for a much larger epidemic
tablatures risk assessment is that the
risk of spread is high nationally and
regionally and globally
nonetheless the signs are extremely
positive in the eastern DRC and I hope
that by the time the emergency committee
reconvenes we will be able to declare an
end to the outbreak but even as we near
the end of this outbreak we must act now
to prevent the next one and we cannot
forget that while this Ebola outbreak
has killed 2001
or denied people measles has killed more
than 6,300 people in DRC in less time
only half of health facilities have
access to water strengthening health
system may not be as sexy as responded
by heartbreak but it is equally
important
tomorrow I'll travel to Kinshasa DRC for
discussions with President Felix Takeda
and other senior ministers about how to
strengthen DRC service system and
protect and promote the health of its
people the current outbreak of kovat 19
highlights why this is so critical our
greatest fear remains the damage this
koruna virus could do in a country like
the RC even at the flames of one
outbreak beginning to die down
we're fighting another five front as of
6 a.m.
Geneva time this morning there are 44
thousand seven hundred thirty cases of
Kobe 19 in China who is 1114 death
outside China there are 441 cases from
two in four countries and one death the
number of newly confirmed cases reported
from China has stabilized over the past
week but last me that must be
interpreted with extreme caution this
outbreak could still go in any direction
the number of countries reporting cases
also has not changed since force
of the 48 new cases confirmed outside
China yesterday 41 on board the dam and
Princess cruise ship which is currently
quarantined in Yokohama we in constant
contact with the Japanese government the
International Maritime Organization and
the owner of the ship to protect the
health of all passengers now we have two
cruise ships that have experienced
delayed port clearance or have been
denied entry through ports often without
an evidence based risk assessment
together with the International Maritime
Organization we will issue a communique
to all countries to respect the
principle of free pratik for ships and
the principle of proper care for all
travelers in accordance with the
international health regulation we have
established lines of communication with
IMO the cruise lines International
Association and the major cruise
operators to ensure accurate information
and can provide the right advice that
miniature has published on how to handle
public health events like this on ships
and weird countries and companies to
follow draft guidance and also pleased
to announce that today Cambodia agreed
to accept the Western dam cruise ship
which has been stranded at sea for
several days based on there are no
suspected or confirmed cases of kovat 90
on board the West at dam the ship will
arrive in Cambodia tomorrow morning this
afternoon I spoke to Cambodia's Minister
of Health to thank him for
in the Western to dock in his country
and I would like to use this opportunity
to also appreciate the government
special his Excellency the Prime
Minister this is an example of the
international solidarity we have
consistently been calling for outbreaks
can bring out the best and the worst in
people
the stigmatizing individuals or entire
Nations does nothing but harm the
response instead of directing moral
energy against the outbreak stigma
diverts our attention and turns people
against each other I will say it again
this is a time for solidarity not stigma
as you know the research and innovation
forum on public 19 concluded this
afternoon I was very encouraged to see
the energy and speed with which the
global research community has taken up
this challenge as we speak research
groups are meeting with the leading
research funders to start work
immediately on the most pressing
questions some of these issues include
easy to apply Diagnostics the best
approach for infection prevention
potential therapies that could be used
to treat patients existing vaccine
candidates and how to accelerate them
and how to address the epidemic we are
also doing deeper investigations to
identify the source of this virus and to
prevent further transmission from
animals to humans that will occur is now
developing a master plan for
coordinating clinical trials
and ensuring they're done coherently and
consistently meanwhile we continue to
support countries with the tools and
equipment they need now to diagnose
cases and protect health workers we have
shipped diagnostic kits to the batteries
around the world and we will continue to
do so and we are also sending supplies
of masks gloves guns and other personal
protective equipment to protect
frontline health workers in 18 countries
that need our support and we have more
in the pipeline
finally our advance team in China has
made good progress in working out the
composition of the team and the scope of
its work we we hope to have more news to
announce soon
thank you thank you for the opportunity
to comment on a few details which we
discussed in the Oval Emergency
Committee we were very pleased about
substantial progress in the two
provinces in which that outbreak has
happened and really the staff active in
the field be the Congo Nationals or
foreigners need to be commended on this
tremendous
I've been a lil very few cases in the
past week and only two health districts
are now affected and as dr. Ted Rose
briefly alluded to the risk assessment
has been downgraded from very high to on
regional and national level
now you may possibly wonder why we
maintain the public health emergency of
international concern this is despite of
cautious optimism because we do see risk
of some resurgence and also a risk of
complacency if we want now suddenly
abandon this thing despite of the fact
that we still occasionally see new cases
and additionally I see two dark clouds
on the horizon there and one is the
continued aggressions which happen and
which compromise the action of the
health teams and the second one is and
here a building a bridge to that verbal
solidarity which you mentioned that is
truly lacking and it is absolutely
paramount that more support is being
offered and so we maintain this thing
but we presume that even before three
months we will reconvene and hopefully
and the good news that we can end the
public health emergency of international
concern that thank you thank you very
much mr. chair so before we open the
floor for questions please one question
per person so we try to get as many as
possible we have about 30 minutes for
questions those online click resize
those dialing star 9 you have just
received from my colleagues the
statement of the Emergency Committee on
Ebola
you also have received press release
regarding the end of the research forum
so we will start here with the room
nougaty
Shane and Katrina very first first
please use your mic or DVD from Latvia
notion of question to the
director-general an article a famous
Chinese people resist is code to say it
have been said that he's expecting that
the crisis will have Bridget speak this
month but it will be critical until
April let's say it will be finished by
April but he doesn't understand why it
is the transmission of this virus is so
quick we would love to be able to
protect the future
but I think we have to be very cautious
the the the stabilization in cases in
the last number of days is very
reassuring as the TG has said and it is
to a great extent the result of the huge
public health operation in China it is
very hard though to predict we
definitely see that the behavior of the
virus outside I'll tell you one who Bay
in the rest of China and outside China
it doesn't appear at this point to be as
aggressive or as accelerating well
that's a good sign
that gives us an opportunity to to
prepare and to react and still gives us
the opportunity for containment and
retention interruption of transmission
of the virus but that's no guarantee
it's not a guarantee but we must
continue to try to stop the virus while
preparing countries for the arrival of
the virus I know that sounds
contradictory but it is not a
contradiction so yes we hope to see the
virus come under control we're not going
to speak about numbers or dates we need
to focus on the task and the task is to
contain the virus to detect cases to
treat the cases if we keep doing those
things yes we may see a drop in the
number of cases but I think it's way too
early to try and predict the beginning
the middle or the end of this epidemic
right now
thank you very much ashamed and Katrina
please yeah okay share in front of the
television CCTV my questions about the
research and innovation forum during the
past two days what do you think about
the participation of the Chinese ax % a
decades and the contributing have to
contributing something to the forum turn
to the study of the corner virus disease
thank you thank you very much so one of
the things that we were very keen is of
course that the Chinese are scientists
and researchers participate in this
meeting because they have the hands-on
experience of what is happening in China
they know what the disease is like what
the local epidemiology and also the
local research that's already started so
we were very fortunate and pleased that
the senior representative from the China
CDC as well as others could participate
in the meeting of course if they did it
remotely because they could not travel
to Geneva but we also had several people
in the room representing China also in
the lead-up to the meeting we've had
several working groups that have been
working on the different thematic areas
and most of the working groups have
Chinese scientists as part of part of
the group so I think the outcomes of the
meeting that were very much influenced
by the contribution of the Chinese
scientists and we're very pleased about
that yes if I may add you know what one
of the major impacts of the presence of
Chinese scientists online was also to
ground the discussion on reality and to
remind the scientists we're there but
this is an issue which is personal now
but there are two things which are
important as said Luigi said stop the
outbreak and
and save lives so what they said was
important is they they needed to have
point of care Diagnostics which were a
validated immediate detection of
infection and the other thing is better
treatment guidelines and better way of
dealing with those was sick and the
intervention as I said grounded the
discussion in the reality and set a
clear goal for for the other scientists
thank you very much dr. Klein thank you
yeah my question is about the master
plan I would like to have more details
about the urgent priorities that have
been decided and also about what you've
decided to mobilize do you decided to
mobilize and ethically for the middle
and lower-income countries how do you
plan to work so there were several
thematic areas that were discussed and
the Chinese scientists who participated
were able to identify what the top
priorities are for them and these were
the development of simpler diagnostics
point of care Diagnostics so that least
could be applied at the community
setting as well as
setting and I think this would be very
useful for other low-income countries to
have a test that could that does not
require the kind of complex laboratory
that a PCR test is needed so I think we
would put this very high up on our list
of priorities secondly it was about
optimal treatment for patients who
become ill and who need hospital
admission what are the best treatment
options standard treatment protocols and
also standard data collection forms that
people all over the world can use those
who are treating these patients and so
we will be able to rapidly collect data
on what the what's working best we also
identified transmission and epidemiology
as an important priority to be studied
fairly quickly because we really need to
understand this virus of course where it
originated and how it jumped to humans
but also about the it's transmissibility
the age groups that it affects what are
the underlying conditions or the
environmental conditions that that
sometimes makes this disease more severe
and some people as opposed to others and
and also what impact the interventions
are having the interventions of
volunteering people of travel blockades
and so on I think will have a lot to
learn from studying all of these there
are other medium-term treat priorities
which include developing vaccines and
therapeutics for this disease so
the immediate faculties and then more
medium-term there are already four
vaccine candidates in development and
it's likely that there will be one or
two that will go into human trials in
about three to four months from now so
that itself would be a very rapid
progress but we the scientists discussed
what would be the framework for
prioritizing which vaccine candidates
then go to further testing
however it would take at least 12 to 18
months for a vaccine to become available
for wider use similarly for therapeutics
there are a number of existing drugs
which have been put forward for testing
and we have agreed that there will be a
master clinical trial protocol that's
developed that again would set out
reactions for the different drugs that
could be tested either singly or in
combination and and and and the faster
we can agree on implementing a protocol
like that they're more likely that we
will get results and be able to to use
those results ready to treat patients
better try to take a few questions from
journalists who are either Thailand in
by phone or watching online so we'll
start with Megan from Wired Megan can
you hear us please
dear me yes we can hear you please go
ahead
great thank you for taking my question I
was wondering if you could provide an
update on the status of the ongoing
clinical trials and try to know right
now how many patients have been dosed
and if we should be expecting the
initiation of any new trials and it
kameez an enemy could you expand on what
exactly
WHS role is going to be with regard to
coordinating such trials in the future
thank you maker verge Chinese colleagues
are very eager to participate in
protocols which have been defined and
which are so that all the clinical
trials are done according to the same
standards and I'm looking towards the
same outcome because you know when you
had a treatment you can measure
different things in other patients so
what is important if you want to compare
different treatment different molecules
is that everybody measures the same so
they were discussion about that they
were very interested in in in working on
such a master protocol so in terms of
the drugs which have been tested and
which are being tested by them currently
they have already dose quite a number
and I don't know how many patients
exactly on a combination
Lupin alley which would be excellent if
you do work because these drug is
available in particular as generate
formulation for the treatment of HIV so
this would clearly be a drug that will
be available this means that we don't
know the result and we have still to
work wait for a few days or a few weeks
to have a result and they will very soon
start to Thomas patient on rainy days
vir we which is an experimental drug
from the producer Juilliard which had
been tested in fact Max's success with
Ebola but Ebola virus and corona virus
are different and may have a better
success with corona but we will have to
wait for a few weeks to know whether
this gives any positive signal to
journalists for my ZAF if you do you
subsequently rain chinese government
crisis management differently
and whether the chinese first informed
and thank you very much
first of all it was about to comment on
the management of the crisis by Chinese
authorities
regulations when the National Health
Commission in Beijing became aware of
the the situation when they notified wh
Armenia under the framework of the ihr
obviously there are normal Fela systems
in place in many countries countries are
in the middle of an influenza season
sometimes it is very difficult to pick
up the signal of an unusual event in
fact this event was picked up by a
surveillance system designed
specifically to think of unusual and
atypical pneumonia and you will remember
that picking up at the time 41 unusually
pneumonias in a population of 23 million
people in the middle of an influenza
season actually if you look at that was
quite picking the needle out of the
haystack and then notifying that to
whu-oh has allowed a massive global
response so I would argue quite the
opposite in fact I would argue that
given the huge population involved and
given the unusual nature of the
pneumonia but which was quite similar to
influenza on presentation it's quite
amazing that the signal was picked up
obviously when the outbreak is over we
can go back and look and all emergency
response we've seen is from all kinds of
emergencies of crisis when you go back
you will almost find things you could
have done better and if anybody involved
in crisis management tells me different
I can tell you after 25 years doing that
that is the truth
but now it's not the time for
recriminations now it's not the time for
forensics now is the time to fight this
virus and we can deal with other issues
later in my view
having said that and the DG has said
this before we always the WH o and we
encourage all countries and most
countries do country made after-action
reviews in which there's a formal
process that looking at all actions are
both leading up to and after an
emergency so we can all learn from the
crisis and learn from our mistakes
everybody makes mistakes in the crisis
that is not the test the test is how you
respond how you react and how you
improve thank you very much take now
question from Paul Ban ki-moon from
French newspaper Le Monde who was
sending me texts every day for the last
couple of days with questions so the
question is because he was not able to
dial in the really antutu to ask
questions so question is what do we know
about transmission chains outside China
Thailand or other countries what can we
say about transmission chains outside to
China from ban ki-moon Paul from Lamont
we can get the exact numbers of my
numbers are going back to to yesterday
of all the cases that we have outside
China only about 22 percent of those
cases are actually due to transmission
outside China within those countries or
third countries so less than a fourth of
those cases reflect the localized
transmission outside China and when we
look at the transmission chains and we
have done a really really forensic job
and looking at each and every one of
those transmission chains and as of this
morning only cases globally we could not
find a plausible explanation for their
exposure well a global level we have a
good view of this virus certainly in
terms of the existing transmission
chains and we have track
in every event each and every
transmission across borders and we tank
countries who have shared their
information with us when we encourage
others who have not to do so because
this is the exact day that that allows
us to track this virus in in the most
detailed way and as director general has
said that doesn't mean that there are
other transmission chains out there
they're quite possibly could be but for
what we see that there that's the
circumstance the other interesting work
that's been carried out is many
countries have accelerated their normal
winter surveillance for for severe acute
respiratory illness and ila and many
countries like Singapore now I think
Singapore stands out there's a really
good example of the country that's
approaching this virus in a very
systematic way are now checking in
emergency rooms all the spirit
reinfection and they're testing for
incoming so them not just testing
against the case definition to testing
all respira treat disease and today
they're not finding in they're not
finding co-winners that they're finding
the flus to finding the other things but
they're not finding a core bit as part
of that now that doesn't mean that that
won't change but in principle at the
moment there's no overwhelming evidence
that this virus is out there causing
efficient community transmission in
other countries now that's a good thing
it doesn't mean it's not happening
but it does again highlight what the
Director General has said again and
again we have a window of opportunity to
shut this virus down to take the
question from katana news agency Tony
Jaime who is asking about a Mobile World
Congress in Barcelona that is due to
take place and apparently the GSMA board
is gathered right now to decide if they
will go on with this Mobile World
Congress
so the question from Tony Hina is what
would be the advice to board deciding if
the Congress should go
I'll pasture the silver for specific
advice but it's really important that
everyone remembers that there is there's
no zero risk with any mass gathering
when we bring people together there's a
risk of food poisoning that can be risks
of of injury buildings have collapsed
all kinds of things that have been
terrorism events have happened all
meeting organizers have to put in place
a risk management strategy in the
context of their never being a zero risk
so what we're advising we're issuing
advice on how to manage a mass gathering
it's very it's easy to ask the question
should we or shouldn't we wh or cannot
become the arbiter of that process what
we can do is offer to systematize
algorithm based decision-making
frameworks that allow each meeting to be
assessed on its merits where it's
happening who's attending and what risk
can be managed many of the risks can be
reduced through very simple measures and
if an event occurs those risks can also
be managed now pastor Sylvie this is a
very important component of our
communication strategy we feel for those
organizations for the uncertainties
associated with these events but we do
believe this risks can be appropriately
managed and again staying calm and
managing those risks in a systematic way
we believe most of these events can
continue if the proper measures are
applied and these don't need to scare
people will be thanks a lot
yes indeed we encourage meeting and mass
gathering organizer to do a risk
assessment because the risk really
depend on us
setting the type of meetings type of
participant and the duration of the
meeting as well and type of room where
the meeting is held etc so there are
many many factors that needs to be taken
into consideration so it's impossible to
give guidance in general we have ready
to look at each setting so we are
providing guidance to help the organizer
to prepare for the meeting to also put
in place some measure during the meeting
and after the meeting so that the risk
is covered not only during the the
meeting itself but before and after as
well so that the risk is managed
throughout the whole process of mass
gathering and meetings and the other
thing is which is very important also
for meeting organizers is to link with
local health authorities just in case
there is some case during the mass
gathering then it can be taken care of
immediately and unsafely and also
effectively thank you very much we go
back to the room
Jami Gabriela and gentlemen here Jamie
first please can you into any of the
microphones
hi Jamie mr. tsipras have a quick
question for dr. terrorist or maybe I'll
try the case count is stabilizing
someone there it appears
the daily death count is rising how do
you explain that the we said before
Jimmy that again through the the work
been carried out with so many patients
being managed in an intensive care
environment and we've seen that the
length of illness is quite long so many
patients now if we take ourselves to the
second week of February are now
reflecting cases who became sick two
weeks ago when we had those peaks and
those library large numbers so what
we're seeing now unfortunately for some
people there are our end-of-life moments
where people have been capitalised
through huge efforts of the help workers
but some people cannot be saved so what
we're not seeing is an increase in the
debt with what we're seeing is an
unfortunate consequence of so many
people been sick and we're at the end of
that cycle and we would hope now as the
numbers drop that we will then see a lag
and a drop in the overall number of
fatalities but again that remains to be
seen
we're not cons we're concerned obviously
the loss of any human life was a tragedy
but in epidemiologic terms we can
explain it through those means thank you
very much Gabriella Sotomayor Mexico a
processor in well I'm not a scientist
obviously but it do you have any
scientific explanation to explain why
there have been no cases in any country
in Latin America or Africa and the
weather
factor for example or something like
that or is it just good luck the Jew
discussed this issue during the your
your meeting because there's a large
Chinese population in some of these
countries thank you
at the beginning of this outbreak we did
some statistic with ayat ah to see the
amount of travelers especially by
playing to different countries around
China and and so we came up with
intensity of traffic from China to
different countries and indeed the first
countries to detect imported cases where
indeed the one who statistically had
more traffic with China so now a few
days after the beginning of the outbreak
and since the lockdown of who ran the
air traffic has decreased a lot of
especially from Wuhan and so now the
pattern we see is is very different from
the pattern we had at the beginning of
the outbreak because obviously many
flights in cancer from one and so the
potential to export from the epicenter
of the outbreak to of the continent has
decreased as well doesn't mean that we
will not see cases in those countries
but it has delayed significantly the
probability to see those cases in other
continents the curve which we have
really time for two more may be cosplay
judgment here and then judgment next -
you can just introduce yourself
from euronews there's reports that China
is changing the way that it is reporting
the figures in that unless people shown
symptoms they will not be classified as
confirmed even if a test comes back
positive what you thought on that and
also secondly looking back at the fuse
of praise that's been given for China
past the Chinese government approached
the w-h-o to ask it to stand up and say
that China he's doing a good job here
was that pressure put on this
organization to say those sorts of
things did the Chinese government say to
the w-h-o that it should give it praise
because I've noticed a few organizations
have done that and I know how important
it is saving face in China so the first
question was that the kind of case the
finishes Oh Mary I think Mike had
already said it and also I can give you
more examples why we recognized what
China is doing for instance the pathogen
was identified at a time record a record
time and immediately they shared the
sequence and when they share the
sequence it helped other countries to
prepare the diagnostic tools to test
cases that by implication means they
have helped actually in preparing other
countries and in preventing the problem
from growing because when you don't test
all badness you know cases will be
missed and
transmission will you know local
transmission can be established in
addition to that the other reason we
appreciate any cognizes I will give you
one example which I said before also
there was a Chinese lady who visited
Germany and she returned to Shanghai and
she was found positive then the Chinese
authorities immediately notified Germany
that a positive person had visited
Germany and that they have to take
action and Germany took that information
and immediately took action to prevent
any serious problem and that's why now
things are under control in Germany so I
think you would agree with me that well
you know it's very important to
appreciate the country or an individual
qualified for something you see that's
the truth
but I don't know few agencies but we
were in this boat for a board meeting
and almost all Member States were
praising China for what it did and they
had a reason the reason others were
saying many countries were saying was
China took action massively at the
epicenter at the source of the outbreak
it's a shutdown of the huahin city and
and that helped in preventing cases from
the exported to other provinces in China
and the rest of the world and I remember
a board member from UK safer button
this is heroic because when you shut
down a city and problems like that it
has consequences economic and so serious
consequences so what's wrong
acknowledging this because they are
saying the actions of China is making us
safer and I know the pressure on that
manager when we appreciate what China is
doing but because of pressure
we should not fail to tell the toffs we
should tell the truth the truth and
that's the truth
China doesn't need to ask to be traced
and I don't expect any country wants to
be asked to be praised it was not it is
not that's the truth the whole truth and
with my colleagues we speak the same
language because we have seen this
concrete things that should be
appreciated I would add one more we have
met the president we have seen the level
of knowledge he has on the outbreak we
saw first and that he is really the
outbreak directly and you know we always
ask for political commitment political
leadership that's what we have seen so
don't you appreciate that kind of
leadership that's really committed again
the truth we don't say anything to
appease anyone it's because it's the
truth
and then I will give you more dimension
to it China is not the first country we
acknowledged we acknowledged other
governments we gave them recognitions in
our assembly for the rightful stated it
helps in two ways one it helps them to
continue doing the right list they're
doing but secondly it helps other
countries to recognized the good
practice that country which is
recognizes the women they can run from
that country that's it but I have been
asked this question many times mike has
been asked this question many times burn
many of our callings Maria Sylvie and so
on our answer is the same it's true that
we have seen many good things that is
slowing the outbreak this is a very
serious virus and China is doing many
good things that slowing the virus and
the facts speak for themselves and this
has to be recognized and the whole world
is seeing this because if you see the
number of cases also in China it's more
than 40,000 but in the rest of the world
that we have less than 400 or around 400
and only one death so let the truth
speak for itself and the world it can
change there is no abstraction here or
there is no what do you call it spinning
here because if the rest of the wounded
had cases especially in the 24 countries
which have reported cases I don't think
they will hide it it's because they
don't have resist that's what we think
so the world the rest of the world is
still safer compared
to one and Hebei province by the way
it's in a better shape and that's why I
always say there is a window of
opportunity so while we have this little
small number of cases 400 and only
wonders there is a window of opportunity
please the world wake up to really
hammer it hammer this virus and prevent
it from being a serious problem or a
crisis in the rest of the world and I
hope you will agree with me that you
take all the factors which ever way
there are things that should be
recognized and because of pressure I
will not stop doing that or saying that
because it's the truth
even if it's just one person staying and
telling the truth I think that should be
the case and we are telling the truth
and we will tell the truth and that's
what we believe I know this is not just
personal to tetris it's our position we
have been together when we traveled my
coach with me but not Roger Smith Sylvie
was with me we have seen what we have
seen and we are giving qualified
recognition and actually my core is
please let's recognize as a portlet as a
globe what China is doing and help them
and show the solidarity if there is any
problem in the process on the earth
break something that they fail to do
there will be challenges there are
challenges I know that will be
weaknesses even China itself is saying
it we will assess that learn from it and
improve for the future but now what's
important is not stigmatizing a country
or attacking a country but stand in
solidarity and fight against this common
enemy
[Music]
Kovach 19 or the virus we have to fight
it in in unison
as humanity because we won and this
virus attacks every human being no one
is immune it's a threat to all of us
so we should start in unison I think
it's time to really unite and attack
this players I was so humbled and I was
so happy today when I sat with
scientists full of this house everybody
was using the same language they said we
will work together there is a common
enemy and we will plan immediate actions
medium and long term and stop this
outbreak as humanity this is a common
agenda to all of us that's what they
said and they have also recognized
focusing on the epicenter and at the
source what China is doing is actually
the right thing to do so it's that kind
of solidarity we need solidarity
solidarity solidarity to be honest let's
not waste our time on saying who is
acknowledging why technology and so on
let's focus on the work let's calm down
no panic no fear and try to do the right
things with solidarity and that's what I
would I would ask me thank you
completely these important words from
there after general
it's technical but it's important so I
think yesterday we had the same
questions and we have checked with our
colleagues who are currently in England
Beijing and also our country office
about this case definition and they send
us the document and so on so first of
all what is important to understand it's
no more during the course of an outbreak
to adapt the case definition because we
need to pick very close to the reality
to monitor the disease how it is
unfolding and the second thing if I can
use an image is like fishing although
I'm not an expert at fishing but if you
want to fish a big fish you will stake a
certain type of nets if you want to fish
small fishes you will take another type
of net so it's normal to change the size
of the net when we want to take a
different type of of fishes and here
it's exactly the same the situation is
evolving so when you are few cases you
have a very sensitive and specific case
definition because you really want to
tie tackle each and every case when the
situation is evolving you change your
definition just to make sure that you
can monitor the disease occurring and
this is what they have done recently
changing the case definition to
incorporate mild cases that were not in
the initial case definition but also
integrated cases that are post
asymptomatic or with limited symptom
because they were testing contacts
around the cases and so this is what has
been done they also try to have a better
case definition for movement proteins
which is a slightly different situation
than the other provinces in China so
that they can also monitors
this is in different places even if the
slippery curve is slightly different so
I hope it answers and could I just add
to the black shift is actually likely to
generate more confirmed cases not less
this is not an attempt to ignore cases
it's an attempt to widen the net and
include milder cases and all that
confirmed cases regardless of the
symptoms so I think if anything it's
actually throwing the knife even wider
with the finer mesh and that's what we
want to see the containment phase and
just one point in reflecting on dr. and
dr. terrazas point I was in meetings
yesterday with colleagues from the
Russian Federation and we were planning
together with our colleagues of the US
for how we're going to celebrate 40
years of smallpox eradication and we
were talking about those heroes who are
left most are people in their 80s and
their 90s now the generation who work
together at the height of the Cold War
across ideologic geographic boundaries
and rid this world of a huge scourge
they didn't see politics or ideology as
a barrier and it's an incredible thing
in a man who ever get a chance to sit
and see those scientists together
who did that service to the world at the
height of tensions in the world and I
think we could really learn from their
work and I weighed humbled me to sit
there to talk about hoping to celebrate
them and it struck me that maybe we have
that same challenge and we need to put
our differences aside we need to fight
this virus together the DGA said it
again and again solidarity is the only
way to defeat this virus
thank you very much so sorry to everyone
who had a question and you were unable
to take it there were other
opportunities as always we will have a
your file available immediately in
transcripts so you can receive all ready
documents from the mercy committee also
we will be we will be done sending also
audio file immediately thank you very
much have a nice evening and in we will
inform you tomorrow about the next media
opportunities thank you
[Applause]
for me
[Applause]
[Music]
Levi you and they in your rolling
african-americans did not quite hear the
phrase see the USA in your Chevrolet the
same way as white Americans did for
African Americans on the road it could
be very very dangerous I'm Alvin Hall a
financial educator broadcaster and
writer the Green Book is the shortened
name for the Negro motorist green book
which was created in 1936 by Victor Hugo
Green Victor Hugo green took advantage
of the fact that he was a member of the
black postman's Union these other posts